hey there folks this is just a quick
video to let you know that youtube
memberships are now
activated for council of geeks if you
wish to support me through that
you now can now i should clarify that
this is not intended to replace or
supersede
patreon support that is still absolutely
going but if you either
want an alternate way or if you're
really nuts an additional way to offer
me support
this is how you can do that and there
are
perks of course for various tiers of
support and those include
access to the council of geeks discord
your name in the closing credits along
with the patreon supporters
and even the occasional exclusive video
like bloopers because i
put those things out and compile them
every now and then but they're not for
the public
you could have access and the one thing
that will be unique to youtube
memberships
custom emotes and badges for the live
streams and the chats during premieres
of new videos so if that sounds good to
you
maybe take a look at the options and
consider supporting me
this is my living and any amount of
support that i get in whatever way i can
get it
is always deeply appreciated but even if
all you did was watch this video to the
end and don't opt to do it you know what
you are still the council
i am just running the meetings hope to
see you around
and until then council's adjourned